so let's take another implicit
derivative of the somewhat crazy
relationship and i've graphed the
relationship here as you can see it is
actually quite bizarre e to the x times
y squared is equal to x minus y this is
a samp this is some of at least in the
range that's depicted here the x's and
the y's that satisfy this relationship
well let's take the derivative of both
sides so we'll apply our derivative
operator
to both sides and actually this is a
good chance to maybe explore some
different notation that's the we we tend
to be using that notation but oftentimes
you will see a derivative operator that
just looks like a big capital d so maybe
we'll do that right over here so let me
make it clear this is
this is the equivalent of saying d over
dx i'll just use this big capital d
operator so that you are familiar with
no no with the notation and instead of
using d y
d x for the derivative of y with respect
to x i'm just going to write that as y
prime so we get a little bit of practice
with different notation
so let's take the derivative of this
thing right over here well we're going
to apply the chain rule actually we're
going to apply the chain rule multiple
times here the derivative of e to the
something with respect to that something
is going to be
e to the something is going to be e to
the
something
times the derivative
times the derivative of that something
with respect to x
so times the derivative of x
y squared so that's our left hand side
we aren't done taking the derivative yet
and on our right hand side the
derivative of x is just 1 and the
derivative with respect to x of y is
just going to be
minus or just i write negative
d y d x but instead of writing d y d x
i'm going to write y prime as you can
see as you can tell i like the i like
this notation and this notation more
because it makes it explicit that i'm
taking the derivative with respect to x
here we just have to assume that we're
here we have to assume that's the
derivative of y with respect to x but
anyway let's stick with this notation
right over here
and every time actually let me make all
my let me make all of my
y primes all of my derivatives with
respect to x all my derivatives of y
with respect to x let me make them pink
so i can keep track of them so once
again this is going to be equal to
e to the x
y squared
times the derivative of this well the
derivative of this we can just use the
product and actually a little bit of the
chain rule here so the derivative of x
is just 1 times the second function so
it's going to be times y squared and
then to that we're going to we're going
to add the product of the first function
which is this x times the derivative of
y squared with respect to x well that's
going to be the derivative of y squared
with respect to y which is just going to
be 2y
times the derivative of y with respect
to x which we are now writing as
which we are now writing as y prime
y prime and then that's going to be
equal to 1 minus y prime
that's going to be equal to 1 minus y
prime and like we've been doing we now
have to just solve for y prime
so let's distribute this exponential
this e to the
x y squared and we get
we get
e or maybe i should say y squared
y squared times e to the x
y squared so that's that
plus
x or let me say 2
x y
e to the x y squared
y prime the derivative of y with respect
to x
is equal to
minus the derivative of y with respect
to x
now let's get all of our y primes on one
side so let's add y prime to both sides
so let's add and just to be clear i'm
adding one y prime to both sides
so let's add a y prime to both sides and
let's subtract this business from both
sides so let's subtract
y squared e to the x y squared to both
sides
by subtracting from both sides so we're
going to subtract y squared e to the x y
squared and we are left with
we are left with
2x
2 x y
e to the x
y squared plus 1 times y prime
times y prime we had this many y primes
and then we add another one y prime so
we have this many plus one y primes
that's going to be equal to that's going
well i purposely
added y prime to both sides and so we
are left with
1 minus is kind of a crazy expression y
squared times e to the x
y squared and now we just have to draw
divide both sides by this and we're left
with the derivative of y with respect to
x is equal to this
which i will just copy and paste
actually let me just rewrite it
it's equal to
1 over
scroll down scroll down a little bit
it's equal to
1 minus
y squared e to the x
y squared
over this business
two
let me give some more space
x y
e to the x y squared
plus one
and we're done it was kind of crazy but
and fundamentally no different than what
we've been doing in the last few
examples